bill are the most talented actors the
ones who make it in Hollywood are the
most talented actors the ones who make
it in the Hollywood that's a very
intriguing question I think that some
actors who make it in Hollywood are very
talented there's some of my heroes the
males Chiefs of the world you know a lot
of people that I love their work but I
think a lot of it's luck looks strategic
alliances and relationships your agent
and a lot of business components so
everybody I see as an actor like you
know Seymour Hoffman unfortunately who
died recently you know acting takes
courage it's not about you know how you
look only but Meryl Streep was in couch
she looks she just surrenders to the
truth of the character not everybody has
the ability to do that they look good
and they can pretend to be that person
not the same as being that person and
there are not many actors that will
surrender to that
you